hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt ich möchte euch heute zeigen
wie man eine tolle mutter torte backen
kann denn wer ist das nächste woche ja
muttertag und ich habe heute diese torte
vorbereitet ich muss jetzt allerdings
zuerst noch erwähnen dass ich heute
wieder im küchenstudio bin und ich
musste über mein letztes video soll
lachen weil ich ja gesagt habe ich habe
meine schütze nicht dabei und musste
eben diese schürze anziehen
aber es sind wirklich keine werbung sein
auch wenn weiß riesengroß schräg drauf
steht aber ohne stürze verklickern ich
mich einfach selbst und heute möchte ich
euch eben diese muttertags karte zeigen
weil sich die viele gewünscht hatten
ich habe es so gemacht dass ich eine
fruchtige torte unter diese von der
schicht gepackt habe und zwar ist es
eine himbeer wickelt orte und falls ihr
euch lindern wie soll ich hier schon
stück herausgeschnitten habe das erfahrt
ihr am ende des videos
und zwar habe ich hier eine himbeer
wickelt orte mit drin
er wickelt orte hatte ich ja schon mal
gemacht und dieses video wird jetzt auch
leider etwas länger aber ich habe
einfach wieder alle schritte mit rein
gebracht so dass er eigentlich danach
keine fragen mehr haben sollten und
direkt mit der torte starten könnt und
damit des videos nicht so lange wird
werde ich jetzt direkt mit der wickel
torte starten und geht dafür jetzt
gleich in die küche und zeige ich dafür
einmal die zutaten
ihr braucht sechs eier 250 gramm zucker
300 gramm mehl ich habe ganz normales
weizenmehl 200 milliliter wasser das
sich setzen sprudelndes mineralwasser
120 milliliter öl geschmacksneutrale öl
eine packung backpulver und hier habe
ich etwas vanilleschote und zwar aus
dieser ganz praktischen gewürzmühle
bevor jetzt den teig zubereitet solltet
ihr auf jeden fall den backofen
vorheizen und euer blech zubereiten
vorbereiten
ich habe jetzt hier meinen back rahmen
auf einem backblech mit backpapier
ausgelegt und da ich hier heute zwei
backöfen haben diese küchenstudio so ist
werde ich auch gleichzeitig noch in
einem backblech backen und zwar habe ich
jetzt heute nur allen park rahmen dabei
wird aber euch ebenso auch zeigen wie
eben der unterschied ist wenn man in mir
mit dem bug rahmen takt und mit dem
backblech und ich werde deswegen aus
diesem tag direkt eine portion teig
zubereiten
aber da er wahrscheinlich nur ein
backofen zu hause habt müsst ihr den
teig halbieren das heißt ihr arbeitet
jetzt erstmal mit 3 1 und nimmt die
hälfte dazu taten packt den einen teig
und dann macht ihr noch mal den gleichen
tag und backt den zweiten tag einfach
deswegen damit der teig jetzt nicht um
steht und dann die luft verliert und das
volumen runtergeht weil dann wird der
teig ziemlich matschig geht's an die
küchenmaschine und weitet sich zu
bereiten
zuerst gibt ihr jetzt eure eier in die
rührschüssel jetzt werde ich das ganze
verrühren und nach und nach den zucker
mit hinzufügen
bis das ganze ebene weiß cremige masse
ist es kann so etwa vier bis fünf
minuten dauern
ihr seht ihr ich habe nichts mit dazu
gegeben und so dick und so voluminös
wird an dieser masse
das geht natürlich auch mit einem
handrührgerät allerdings dauert es da
viel viel länger und ich weiß gar nicht
ob man das überhaupt mit dem
handrührgerät so in diesem maß
hinbekommt also bei mir lief die
kitchenaid jetzt etwa vier minuten mit
einem handrührgerät würde ich auf jeden
fall 15 bis 20 minuten laufen lassen
jetzt gebe ich hier die wanne mit dazu
jetzt liebe ich mein mail obwohl dieses
globus mail muss man gar nicht sieben
weil wie ihr seht macht es gar keine
klümpchen aber das ist ein ganz normales
405 weizenmehl und jetzt gebe ich auch
direkt das öl und das wasser medizin und
verrührte sitzt ganz langsam mit einem
schneebesen mitte zwischen dickflüssig
der teig ist und so soll es auch sein
diesen teig halbiere ich jetzt auf meine
zwei backbleche aber wenn ihr eben jede
portion nur einmal macht gibt ihr den
teig jetzt in eure form und packt ihn
und gleich im anschluss müsst ihr noch
mal die hälfte des rezepts machen also
mit drei eiern weil ihr einmal einen
boden und einen deckel benötigt und die
müsst ihr in einer springform mit dem
durchmesser von 24 zentimetern backen
meine beiden teigplatten werde ich jetzt
bei 200 grad ober und unterhitze backen
für etwa neun minuten natürlich müsst
ihr die stäbchen probe machen mit dem
zahnstocher und schauen dass da nichts
dran hängt die teigplatten müssen bei
200 grad gebacken werden damit sie
einfach schnell backen und beim bak
nicht austrocknen weil wir sehr später
wickeln werden und sie dann eben noch
schön saftig bleiben sollen
deswegen werde ich jetzt in den ofen
schieben und zeigt euch dann das
endergebnis
ihr seht jetzt bei mir im hintergrund
sie zwei backbleche die hier gerade
abkühlen und dem open habe ich jetzt den
runden kuchen einmal hier einmal da also
habe ich insgesamt vier böden gebacken
oder vier tage und jetzt weil ich
einfach die zwischenzeit nutzen um
bereits meine garage zu stellen weil ich
heute eine fruchtige hinterfüllung habe
möchte ich jetzt eine weiße ghanas aber
ihr könnt jetzt zum beispiel auch den
teig als schoko teig backen und jetzt
hier auch eine dunkle ghanas nehmen da
schreibe ich euch aber dann auch die
genaue mengenangaben einfach in meinen
blog und werdet ihr euch einmal die
zutaten für die ghanas zeigen und wird
jetzt einfach kurz herstellen und zwar
wie ich jetzt hier 70 milliliter sahne
und 200 gramm weiße schokolade die habe
ich einfach schon in die rippen
gebrochen
die sahne gebe ich jetzt in einen topf
und setzt jetzt auf höchster stufe schön
erhitzen und bis mein mann die kameras
eingestellt hatte ist die sahne schon
aufgekocht wie es seht und hört einfach
wieder abschalten und sie die sahne
runter und jetzt könnt ihr da einfach
die schokolade mit reingeben schaut dass
sie schön gedeckt ist mit der sahne also
ein bisschen hin und her schwenken
jetzt wird sich die schokolade in der
warmen milch auflösen und ich früher das
jetzt so lange bis sich die schokolade
komplett aufgelöst hat und jetzt ist die
garage auch schon fertig da gebe ich
jetzt den topf deckel drauf stelle das
ganze in den kühlen raum aber nicht in
den kühlschrank und lass es einfach
schön abkühlen bis es so eine nutella
artige konsistenz hat so sollte es dann
zum schluss aussehen also ich habe jetzt
hier vorne zweimal die eckigen kuchen
und hier zwei runde und wie ihr sehen
könnt das ist jetzt ein ganz gutes
beispiel die zwei runden die durften
gleich lange packen beide bei 200 grad
aber ihr seht ihr der da vorne ist etwas
dunkler als der da hinten und das ist
das was ich immer sage nämlich dass
jeder ofen anders packt das heißt denn
hier hätte ich ein bisschen früher
rausnehmen sollen aber da ist auch so
noch prima und mein mann zeigt jetzt mal
die stäbchen probe und zwei hier klebt
nichts mehr dran da auch nicht das heißt
der tigers durch ich lasse jetzt hier
schön ab
innen und weg hier vorne weitermachen
meine bizkit böden sind jetzt abgekühlt
meiner garage gestellt und jetzt werde
ich die füllung vorbereiten und dazu
zeige ich euch jetzt hier einmal die
zutaten
ich habe hier 500 gramm himbeeren und
zwar sind es tiefgefrorene die habe ich
allerdings auftauen lassen
ihr könnt aber natürlich auch frische
produkte nehmen aus dem eigenen garten
zb und die früchte können natürlich auch
austauschen wie ihr das gerne möchte ich
habe hier 500 gramm magerquark eine
halbe zitrone für den also hier brauchen
wir den zitronensaft für die die es
gerne etwas zitronig mögen
ich habe hier drei esslöffeln apart und
zwar ist es ein rein pflanzliches sahne
verteidigungsmittel das bräuchten jetzt
allerdings nicht weil ich hier noch
ärgert ihn habe aber bei dem sommerbad
habe ich den vorteil dass es direkt
verliert also die masse wird direkt fest
und das sage ich euch auch später was
das 5 vorteil hat ich habe 60 gramm
puderzucker 300 milliliter sahne dies
muss ganz kalt sein
und hier habe ich jetzt noch zwei tüten
magazine und zwar ist es hier jetzt von
der marke ruf gibt es aber auch von
anderen marken und zwar ist es rein
pflanzlich und wer keine akademie hat
kann auch gelatine nehmen
aber ich bevorzuge immer ganz gerne die
pflanzliche variante wenn es eine gibt
und deswegen habe ich jetzt hier die ak
tine ihr könnt aber stattdessen auf 12
blatt gelatine nehmen
ich habe in meinem shop auch in der
latina aber wie gesagt wenn ich die
möglichkeit habe etwas pflanzliches
zunehmenden bevorzuge ich das lieber
weil ich das einfach etwas besser finde
statt immer zu tierischen produkten zu
greifen und das ist jetzt so die
alternative die ich immer ganz gerne
benutzt außerdem ist die akademie
geschmacks und geruchsneutral und passt
deswegen perfekt zu allen füllungen
ich werde jetzt aus diesen zutaten die
füllung herstellen und wer jetzt
deswegen noch mal in die küche gehen an
die küchenmaschine meine himbeeren sind
aufgetaucht wie bereits gesagt und die
müssen jetzt noch püriert werden
und ich werde es jetzt heute in diesem
mixa machen ich kenne den mixer nicht
ich hoffe er funktioniert weil ich es
nicht in meiner eigenen küche stehen für
rohstoffe
das kann man auch mit pürierstab machen
das geht natürlich auch oder jedem
anderen mixa und ist könnt ihr das
direkt in den topf geben oder wenn ihr
keine kerne
gibt passiert ihr das durch ein haarsieb
aber ich werde es jetzt mit den kernen
nehmen
ich finde es schmeckt einfach natürlich
hat es gehört mit dazu und ihr erspart
euch einen arbeitsschritt zu den neben
bayern gibt jetzt die zwei tüten
magazine mit dazu
falls ihr jetzt hier mit gelatine
arbeitet kommt die gelatine nicht direkt
mit rein da musst du einfach mal auf der
packungsanleitung schauen weil es
nämlich ethische latina anders bei blatt
gelatine müsse vorher in kaltem wasser
einweichen und zu den warmen hin bändern
dazugeben und die gemeine gelatine ist
ihr in abgemessenen kaltem wasser
einweichen etwas quellen lassen und dann
kommt die eben auch in die warme himbeer
masse mit dazu hierbei der akademie ist
es so dass die akademie mit zur kalten
masse kommt dann muss man das ganze
zusammen aufkochen lassen und dann darf
bis zwei minuten weiter köcheln
und wenn es dann zwei wochen durfte
können das vom herd unternehmen und am
besten was dir das auch euren mamas
spritzt nämlich das stelle ich jetzt
einfach hier weg vom hemd dass es etwas
abkühlen kann denn so heiß dürfen wir
das jetzt nicht benutzen
die hindern können jetzt mit der
akademie zusammen ab und ich werde jetzt
hier mal meine sahne steif schlagen und
wird dann während dem rührendes an apart
mit einrühren wenn ihr kein sommerbad
habt ist es wirklich nicht schlimm das
könnt ihr einfach weglassen
das hilft jetzt einfach nur dass die
masse gleich schneller fest wird und ich
dann schneller damit arbeiten kann wenn
ihr das nicht habt müsste einfach später
etwas länger warten bis die creme
abkühlt
und wenn die sahne steif ist kommt sie
in den kühlschrank
und dann könnt ihr direkt mit dem quad
weitermachen und zwar braucht es auch
gar nicht zu putzen weil dass er die
gleiche masse ergibt dann kommt nämlich
der quark in die rührschüssel das mache
ich jetzt kratzt sehr umständlich da
kommt jetzt der puderzucker mit dazu
besser natürlich wenn ihr den sieg aber
mein haar slider nass und hier gebe ich
es noch etwas zitronensaft mit rein
können dass so viel mit rein geben wie
ihr möchtet
und das hier wird jetzt nur ganz kurz
verrührte sich auch ganz wichtig weil
ansonsten der quark nämlich flüssig wird
das heißt es jetzt nur so lange bis sich
der quark mit dem zucker mit dem
zitronensaft vermischt hat also 210
ungefähr fünf sekunden
wenn überhaupt dann sieht es so aus und
wir schauen uns jetzt mal die himbeer
magazine masse an
im fernsehen jetzt mittlerweile so aus
ist jedes dampft immer noch also ist es
immer noch zu heiß wenn ich das jetzt
nämlich zum quark meter zu geben wird
der cvag flüssig und die creme eben
nicht mehr so schön cremig
deswegen lasse ich das jetzt so weit
abkühlen bis es etwas dickflüssiger
geworden ist bis es nicht mehr dampf
also bis es eigentlich fast hand warm
geworden ist das können wir als
beschleunigen indem ich das jetzt
einfach schnell um fülle damit das jetzt
hier schneller funktioniert und wenn das
schön abgekühlt ist
dann geht es weiter und so lange werde
jetzt auf dem quad in den kühlschrank
stellen
dann gebt ihr einen esslöffel von der
quarkmasse zu den warmen himbeeren mit
dazu und verrührt es schön und es ist
auch ganz wichtig damit ihr das so
verrührt damit da eben keine verliert
ein stückchen dann entstehen wenn ihr
die quarkmasse direkt mit der warmen hin
bei masse in berührung bringt dann könnt
ihr anschließend die himbeer masse mit
zum quark mit dazu geben und das ganze
schnell verrühren
das geht auch ganz gut mit der
küchenmaschine den rest ruhig dann mit
hand unter und dass das ganze kurz
stehen bis ich meine tortenplatte
vorbereitet habe
ich lege einen tortenring um einen
runden tortenboden und werde mich jetzt
um die teigplatten kümmern und zwar
schneide ich dir jetzt in 7 cm streiten
und neben mir da den bug kamen zu hilfe
und so könnt ihr individuell bestimmen
wie hoch ihre wickelt orte seien die
teig streifen sind als vorbereitet und
ihr seht jetzt auch hier die creme wurde
etwas fester das ist auch gut so
ihr müsst da einfach nur darauf achten
dass jetzt nicht sofort fest wird sodass
eben noch damit arbeiten können und das
ist auch der vorteil mit diesem sun
abfahrt also klar würde jetzt auch die
bindekraft von der ak tine ausreichen
aber dadurch dass es die sahne auch
schön fest ist ist es jetzt gleich alles
richtig schön streichfähig und es
verläuft mir dann eben nicht beim drauf
streichen
salat gibt es nicht überall also das
gibt's in grösseren supermärkten aber
ich werde jetzt auch mal versuchen das
selbst herzustellen denn die zutaten das
sind nur drei stück und zwar stärker
mehl und zucker und ich glaube dass das
mit der becker stärke ganz gut
funktionieren könnte
das tüfteln ich jetzt mal daheim aus
denn der vorteil von san apathisch
einfach dass es streu fähig ist und
einfach nicht klumpt und das lässt sich
einfach mal
dann nehmt ihr euch jetzt eure füllung
und gibt sie großzügig auf die
teigplatten und zwar nehmen die
deutschen natürlich die hälfte der
erfüllung weil er zwei teigplatten habt
und könnten mit hilfe der winkel palette
und eures vaters des schönen verteilen
und hier seht ihr auch schon dass die
füllung richtig schön streichfähig sein
muss nicht weglaufen darf einfach damit
zu euch da jetzt nicht runter läuft und
jedes schön verteilen könnt ich sehe
jetzt auch selbst wenn euer tag
vielleicht nicht gleichmäßig gebacken
wurde
könnt ihr das mal mit der creme schön
ausgleichen so ich mir nochmal die
stelle an der ich geschnitten hatte und
mag ihr das foto vor augen und nehmen
mit la palette erstmal da unten locker
ich das nochmal und das erste stück wird
jetzt gerollt und zwar rollt es einfach
schön auch richtig hunger und setzt es
einfach so in die mitte einfach mitten
rein sieht das unten nochmal lösen
und wenn euch das so zu lang ist weil es
ist echt schwierig das dann so zu nehmen
falls ihr euch das sie sieht man nämlich
später gar nicht und setzt es jetzt hier
dran und es wird jetzt alles
spiralförmig eben hier zusammengerollt
und so macht ihr das bis die komplette
form ausgefüllt ist und da kann es sein
dass ihr die kompletten zwei bleche
verbraucht kann aber auch sein dass er
nur eine halb vielleicht braucht
deswegen machen wir immer zwei bleche
und es reicht dann auf jeden fall
ich bin ihr könnt auch den rand erst mal
weglassen
es geht dann einfacher ich werde es noch
eine zweite platte bestreichen und macht
und hier gleich weiter
mit gebt ihr einfach den tortenring
außen herum und zieht ihn schön fest
und dann kommt nämlich auch eure ganze
torte richtig schönen form und ist jetzt
auch das geht wie eine strecke von innen
nach außen
und damit das ganze jetzt oben im
schönen abschluss gibt nehme ich mir ein
messer setzt es hier direkt am
tortenring an und schnellste weg weil
dann habe ich auf die gleiche höhe und
meine torte isst ebenmäßig nehmen da
immer gleich weg wünschen die schliche
ganz geheim ein konditor messe habe ich
leider nicht dabei
und dann gebe ich da den deckel nach
oben drauf und dann nehmt ihr euch den
flachen teller oder einen torten retter
und setzt den oben drauf ich habe es
leider keinen runden und so lagert ihr
das ganze dann im kühlschrank für etwa
zwei bis drei stunden
den rest ihr tun müsst ihr gar nicht
wegschmeißen ich finde nämlich
lebensmittel wegzuschmeißen
dass ich eines der schlimmsten dinge die
man überhaupt tun kann und zwar ziemlich
jetzt hier auch noch den bis kritsch mit
dazu den brauche ich ja nicht mehr und
dann schicht ich das ganze einfach in
ein glas und dann kann man das super als
glas bisher auf essen
da gebe ich noch ein paar von den
hintern dazu so sieht es dann fertig in
den gläsern geschichten aus meine torte
war für etwa zwei bis drei stunden im
kühlschrank und ist schön fest geworden
sie ist auch jetzt richtig schön kalt
und jetzt werde ich sie mit etwas kanal
frisch streichen damit ich sie später
mit davon dann decke belegen kann
wenn ihr jetzt die torte nicht mitfahren
dann einen kleinen wollt könnt ihr auch
eine buttercreme neben stadtdekanat das
ist dann etwas anders im geschmack ihr
könnt zum beispiel auch eine frisch
käsecreme nehmen die ist dann etwas
leichter im geschmack oder ihr könnt die
torte einfach mit etwas sahne verzieren
ich zeige euch jetzt einfach wie ich die
garage auf die torte bringe sie schön
glatt streiche ich habe hier nicht das
ganze werkzeug dabei was ich sonst immer
zu hause habe aber ich dass ich so gut
wie möglich zu machen ist jedes tier das
sich der teig rahmen ganz leicht
entfernen lässt
und jetzt nehme ich einfach meine garage
und verstreicht sie ganz glatt auf
meinem teig auf dem kuchen und da habe
ich auch schon andere videos dazu da
könnt ihr dann schritt für schritt sehen
wie man so eine torte richtig schön glas
bekommt
meine garage ist richtig schön fest
geworden und ich habe jetzt hier schon
etwas weißem von und habe ihn weiß
geknotet so gut es ging da ist heute
etwas hart und zweiten ausrollen und
damit an die torte eindecken zum
ausrollen verwende ich immer meinen
silikon aus rolf starb und etwas becker
stärke weil es so einfach am besten
funktioniert und rollt es jetzt soweit
aus wie ich das brauche
anschließend lege ich dann meine front
und decke auf meine torte und streicht
stellen die ränder aus glättet das ganze
mit meinem fondant blätter und schneidet
die überstehenden teig länder ab
und so gebe ich jetzt den kuchen in den
kühlschrank on wetzel andere deko
vorbereiten
und ich möchte euch jetzt heute eine
technik zeigen mit der er ganz toll
torten dekorieren könnt und zwar ist es
die quilling technik und dazu habe ich
jetzt einfach etwas modelliermasse
genommen ihr könnt auch nur von hand
nehmen modelliermasse ist fondant und
blüten passte eins zu eins vermischt und
die habe ich jetzt in rot gewählt und
knetet jetzt schon seit einer ewigkeit
dass sie schön weich wert und jetzt habe
ich hier meinen utl vorsatz für die
kitchenaid eingesetzt und ihr könnt das
ganze jetzt aber auch mit einem ganz
normalen aus hollstadt machen oder mit
einer nudelmaschine dir zu hause habt
ich mache jetzt natürlich so weit so
viel schneller geht und wird jetzt meine
modelliermasse hierdurch geben damit sie
dünn ausgerollt wird macht es ist aber
auch nicht zu dünn und ich hab jetzt in
meiner kitchenette noch den anderen auf
sand ist und zwar den photokina aufsatz
der schneidet mir nämlich die blüten
passte oder die modelle masse direkt in
feine streifen das ist ja eigentlich so
nudel aufsatz und es passt jetzt
wirklich perfekt da muss ich das nämlich
nicht mit dem messer schneiden
ich habe hier meinen backpapier
vorbereitet und habe mir auf die
rückseite und herz gezeichnet weil das
die form ist die ich machen möchte
aber ihr könnt natürlich auch jede
andere form nehmen oder einfach nur was
schreiben und hier werde ich jetzt diese
technik anwenden und zwar nehmt ihr euch
da jetzt diese einzelnen streifen und
ich zeige euch jetzt einfach mal wie es
geht
wollt ihr das eine ende zusammen dass
ich am anfang ein bisschen knifflig und
rollt dann das andere ende
entgegengesetzt zum beispiel und so
könnt ihr das jetzt mit verschiedenen
farben machen und einfach verschiedene
formen legen das muss jetzt einfach
erstmal noch gar kein muster ergeben
sondern einfach ganz viele kleine die
wir später dann zu einem großen
verbinden und hier gestaltet jetzt so
viele kleine elemente bis eure form
ausgefüllt ist und gebt alles schön mit
leber zu sein
so sieht jetzt unser herz aus mein mann
hat mir natürlich fleißig geholfen beim
drehen und wickeln und ich hab das
zwischendrin immer wieder mit zucker
kleber hier angeklebt damit die
einzelnen teile einfach schön
zusammenkleben und damit man die
konturierte besser sieht werde ich jetzt
noch so ein rotes stück nehmen und das
einmal außen herum legen natürlich hoch
kommt
und jetzt habe ich nochmal hier roten
form dann und möchte jetzt um die torte
noch ein schönes bank legen einfach
damit der abschluss schön ist und damit
ich einfach noch ein paar dekoelemente
habe und ich zeige euch jetzt einfach
hier ganz schnell wie das geht es
funktioniert nämlich ganz einfach und
ich habe hier noch einen ganz schönen
aus rom starb da setzt euch auch den
link in der infobox und zwar sind es
handgemachte struktur stäbe und mit
diesem hier werde ich jetzt gleich mal
entfernt
schönaus rollen einfach nur mal die
struktur geben und wird dann dieses
herzchen band um eine torte legen ich
habe jetzt meinen band schon ausgerollt
es geht ganz einfach mit der
nudelmaschine und jetzt rolle ich ganz
langsam diese herz struktur roller
drüber danach schneide ich unten einen
sauberen run tab damit eben unten die
kante schön glatt ist und werde dann mit
meinem schneider rädchen das band
wellenförmig ausschneiden
anschließend wie pinsel ich dann meine
torte mit etwas zucker kleber und rolle
dann das band schön auf da ist es
nämlich einfach hat es auf die torte zu
transportieren und dann könnt ihr das
einfach am rand der torte entlang wieder
aufholen und es gleichzeitig festkleben
am rand passte das ganze dann mit einem
messer an also mit seinem vater
berichtet weil es dann damit einfacher
geht ich kann den übergang richtig schön
sauber abschneiden des band festkleben
und dann habt ihr euer richtig schön
gestaltetes herzchen band um eure torte
gelegt mein herz ist jetzt ausgetrocknet
das herz können dir auch schon zwei tage
vorher machen damit sie durch trocknet
und ich habe es jetzt mit meinem teig
retter mit meinem torten retter an
liegst mir auf meine hand drauf und
streich etwas kleber drauf und platz ihr
das herz dann dort wo ich es eben
hinhaben möchte mein mann wollte jetzt
noch ein paar rosen auf der torte haben
also zeige ich euch jetzt noch ganz
schnell wenn man kleine rosen machen
kann und zwar braucht ihr fünf kleine
kugeln aus modelliermasse die drückt ihr
alle platz und streicht sie zur hälfte
mit etwas kleber 1
das erste stück vom land so einer
kleinen wurst und legt dann die anderen
plätzchen einfach außen rum in dem ihr
immer wieder die kanten überdeckt
zum schluss zwickt ihr unten dann noch
den überstand weg das könnte auch ganz
gut mit einer schere machen und schon
habt ihr eure eigene kleine hose
hergestellt
dann könnt ihr die fertigen größten
einfach mit etwas zucker kleber auf der
rückseite an eurer party casting
und so sieht dann meine fertige torte
aus und jetzt habe ich nur in ganz
kleinen tipp für euch und in ganz guten
und zwar meistens so dass die von der
oberfläche er etwas matt aussieht durch
die bäcker stärke oder den puderzucker
dinge benutzt und dann hilft etwas kaka
spray und zwar ist es ganz einfach
kakaobutter und die sprüht man auf den
tipp habe ich nämlich von einem
bäckermeister bekommen und ich werde
versuchen dieses spray auch in meinem
job zu bekommen da suche ich jetzt noch
einen guten anbieter und ich zeige euch
einfach mal den effekt natürlich soll er
dessen muttertags torte sein und ich
würde jetzt wenn sie jetzt für muttertag
gemacht wäre noch irgendwie für meine
mama oder führte liebe mama danke mama
und irgendwas draufschreiben aber der
muttertag erst nächste woche ist
schreibe ich dass es nicht drauf weil
ich die torte jetzt einfach an jemand
ganz liebe schenken verschenken möchte
und zwar bekommt die torte der liebe
sven weil er uns hier diese küche zur
verfügung stellt und wir jetzt hier
drehen durften
ich schreib das jetzt einfach mal an ich
nicht drauf zeugen ja ich stecke das
stück einfach wieder zurück ja aber ich
muss sich zeigen
das tut mir jetzt auch weh aber er wird
mir verzeihen sind wir alle gespannt ob
alles geklappt hat
und so sieht dann die wickel torte von
innen aus ich könnte reinbeißen okay ist
und jetzt steckt irgendwo wieder zu ohne
zu probieren
natürlich gibt es ganze rezept mit allen
informationen noch mal auf meinem blog
nachzulesen auf sell list orten welt.de
ich werde jetzt die torte gleich
verschenken man sieht eigentlich auch
kaum das gehört einfach mit zur deko und
ich werde am mittwoch noch mal ein video
hochladen für muttertag da versuche ich
jetzt heute schon mal was ganz
besonderes und zwar wird es eine torte
mit einem ganz tollen innenleben und ich
hoffe dass es klappt wenn es nicht
klappt dann gibt es eben ein anderes
video aber ich bin zuversichtlich dass
es klappt sie suchen genau wenn es nicht
klappt gibt es ein super und ich wünsche
euch auf jeden fall ganz viel spaß beim
nachbacken falls ihr das ausprobiert ich
würde mich natürlich freuen wenn ihr
mehr bilder auf facebook oder instagram
postet oder mehr einen kommentar und
eine bewertung da lasst ihr dürft auch
gerne mein video teilen ich weiß es
wurde jetzt ein etwas längeres video
aber ich habe euch jetzt einfach so
viele schritte gezeigt und so viele
sachen auf einmal
und deswegen wird es jetzt einfach mal
ein längeres video und ich hoffe es hat
euch trotzdem spaß gemacht und wir sehen
uns beim nächsten mal wieder fußball
und hier könnt ihr noch sehen was ich
für eine kommunion skate gemacht hatte
für diesen sonntag und zwar war es für
die ciena die hatte sich eine kumulierte
von mir gewünscht und die habe ich am
gleichen tag noch gebacken
das war auch mal so dass mein vater da
sag ich
er hatte keinen kratzer meisters auto
und sollte aber morgen ist es am ihrer
kita garten fahren und hatte ich hab
kein eiskratzen ich hab kein eiskratzen
und hab ich mal von der tankkarte
mitgegeben hat dadurch nur datei karte
frei gekratzt
ich habe übrigens seitdem eine eine
tankkarte weniger also du solltest du
vielleicht mal wieder vorbei trinken
satz noch zu schauen dass alle von mir
die ideen sind alle von meinem mann und
er hat hier ganz fleißig mit gewohnt
bissig echt so geben
ich habe alles unter kontrolle und es
später nicht kannst du gerne deshalb
habe ich mir noch die andere sache
die super darf arthur auslöffeln